Welcome to our new video in this series
The Good the Bad and the stupid where we
are going to be looking at some of the
best some of the worst and some of the
most different ways of doing stuff in
sci-fi this time space travel welcome to
Sidetrack here Sci-Fi TV and movie
channel
[Music]
a lot of sci-fi happens in space and
space is quite big so a lot of sci-fi
writers have had to have a think about
what are the best ways to get around the
vast blackness
now sometimes they've actually put a lot
of effort into that and sometimes one of
the longest running sci-fi shows in
history put no effort into it whatsoever
so let's crack on with the list first of
all we're going to be talking about the
good now I'm going to split this
category into two the most realistic and
actually best thought through way of
traveling through space in sci-fi and
another which is probably the most
realistic way of traveling faster than a
light so first of all we're going to be
talking about realism in sci-fi of
course we're going to talk about the
expanse in the expanse series Solomon
Epstein invented a fusion drive a slight
Twist on the existing technology that
meant instead of having to accelerate
just for short periods during the
journey it allowed the engines to burn
continuously allowing for continuous
acceleration when traveling between two
objects now the Epstein drive basically
opened up the solar system now NASA has
actually already looked at Technologies
like this using things like an iron
Drive an ion drive basically means that
you can use a very small amount of fuel
and you can accelerate not particularly
hard but you can accelerate for long
periods of time now that would allow an
object where there's no resistance as in
space to accelerate for long periods
building up speed over time now NASA
estimates that an engine like this would
be able to accelerate a vehicle up to
0.7 or 0.8 the speed of light now that
is pretty damn quick it means that we
could get to Stars reasonably close to
us say a star that is five light years
away within six or seven years now that
considering the distance is pretty damn
impressive within a solar system it
would mean you could get between planets
within a couple of days
now that really would mean the solar
system would be opened up to space
travel and that's exactly where they
went with the expanse Series in this
Epstein Drive they even went as far as
remembering that any object traveling
through space needs just as much energy
and effort to accelerate as it does to
then stop again
so the Epstein drive you would use it
and accelerate continuously towards
where you were going and then halfway
there you would flip and then start
burning the engines equally to slow you
back down again now most Sci-Fi series
forget that point they think that if you
turn the engines off Star Trek is guilty
for this all the damn time that if you
suddenly get a lot of power to the warp
drive or even the impulse engines you
suddenly come to a stop
it's just not true so that for me is why
the Epstein drive from the expanse wins
the good it is by far the most realistic
and the most thought through method of
traveling through space that I've ever
come across in sci-fi
but how about traveling faster than
light if you want to go between the
stars and you want to do that in a TV
show or a movie you need to be able to
do it quite quickly for this one I'm
actually going to say Star Trek has done
the best job they've had a long time to
flesh out some of the technology some of
the ideas but more than that NASA
actually agrees to creating a warp
bubble that they talk about in Star Trek
is actually physically possible they're
saying that traveling at faster than the
speed of light is no longer a matter of
science it's acting a matter of
engineering it's not if it's how so what
does a warp drive actually do well in
theory what you're doing is you're not
breaking the speed of light instead what
you're doing is bending space time
you're actually bending and forcing
space around you to change you're
pulling the space in in front of you and
then you're pushing the space out behind
you so you're only relatively to the
rest of the universe actually traveling
faster than the speed of
in reality you don't instead you change
the road instead of trying to drive down
the road faster Miguel alcubiere
actually did a paper on this very
subject and created the alcubiere drive
now Nash has been able to do an awful
lot of maths and apparently you need to
take an object the size of kind of like
a moon and condense it down to the size
of a marble to create a dense enough
Force to actually distort space-time and
create that warp bubble
that will be quite difficult but not
impossible so perhaps one day we will
actually get to see faster than light
spaceships powered by Star Trek's warp
drive the bad now I'm only going to use
this example mainly because this is the
longest running Sci-Fi show arguably on
television
and they have never ever tried to
actually give us any detail on how the
Tardis in Doctor Who works now we know
there's an artificial Singularity at the
core of the TARDIS we know within Doctor
Who's Tardis that that is called the eye
of Harmony and it is like semi-conscious
it actually jumped into a humanoid at
one point and used to talk to the doctor
quite a bit
now I don't want to put this into the
stupid category because I actually have
a faster than light drive that is
completely stupid in mind but I put it
into the bad category because even
though they threw quite a lot of techno
Babble I mean the word Tardis actually
stands for time and relative dimensions
in space and is able to travel through
time and space
but they never actually bothered
explaining any of the science or any of
the detail of how it actually worked it
just did now that was fine for the
Sci-Fi back in the day but the fact that
it has gone on this long and we really
don't have any more detail on that as a
Sci-Fi fan I find that annoying I am a
geek I like to know these things work
and they've been so vague at times in
Doctor Who I just have to say come on do
bear the displacement activated Spore
Hub Drive in Star Trek discovery
is stupid
the basic theory behind this is the
entire universe is filled with a
mycenaeus Spore and they're actually
life forms that live in this kind of
harmony with this sport that the spores
are very much like the spores you would
get from a mushroom but a galactic
mushroom
comes across like something from Douglas
Adams you know you're expecting the
Earth to be balanced on a tall choice to
be balanced on a monkey to be balanced
on a massive mushroom that doesn't never
made any sense to me now during certain
episode of Star Trek Discovery we learn
more about the sport drive that
apparently according to Federation
Starship engineers and scientists that
at a Quantum level there is virtually no
difference between biology and physics
I'd question that and that actually the
spores not only fill the universe they
are actually important and fundamental
for the creation and maintenance of
energy within that universe
now for some reason when the discovery
needed to enter
um the mycenial plane
and actually travel from one place to
another instantaneously along that my
senior plane it needed to spin round and
then weirdly drop
don't know I did that look kind of cool
don't know why it did that and then also
it then dropped back into um frame when
it then appeared wherever it needs to go
incredibly powerful technology that the
Federation then just forgot about now
that I know they explain that in the
series but they didn't explain it well
now this honestly was one of the reasons
why I didn't actually like Discovery
particularly I thought this mycenial
drive even if it had some basis in some
sort of science which I I don't get
maybe it's above my head you're like
when you start getting quantum mechanics
anything's almost possible so I'll give
them that even though it sounds
ridiculous lots of things in quantum
mechanics do
but more to the point it's stupid
because it's lazy writing allow the land
of Discovery to just bounce around
everywhere it was yeah okay it was
Greece is a great weapon but then even
though it was used as a weapon and the
Klingons would have seen this ship just
appear and disappear from nowhere and
apparently as well they would have seen
it disappear and then reappear somewhere
else
it was a complete secret and nobody knew
about it again that seemed to me like
completely lazy writing I know it
allowed them to do lots of things within
the story but to be honest
it was just badly written it was badly
conceived and it was just
dare I say it
stupid
so that is my list for The Good the Bad
and the stupid of traveling through the
big black I'd love to know though what
have I forgotten about get into the
comments tell me some of the you know
Starship designs or engines or ways of
getting around the Galaxy that you
either loved or hated if you are a bit
of a Sci-Fi geek things like this matter
to you so what do you actually think get
into the comments and tell me
if you are new to the Channel please
like subscribe hit that Bell
notification it really helps us out and
you'll never miss any of our new videos
also you can go to patreon.com forward
slash Sidetrack that one and you get to
see most of our new videos first and for
a small contribution each month that
really supports the channel and helps us
keep going you get to see them without
the adverts if you even get a free gift
after three months
as always please stay safe and I'll see
you next time
foreign
[Music]